- Our choreographer's amazing.
She's Jessica Castro, and she worked with
Mariah Carey and Alicia Keys.
- Never heard of them.
(laughter)
- Yeah, and J Lo.
And she sat me down and she's like,
"Look, you're playing a pop-star,
you need to know about the hair whip."
And I'm like,
"Well, what do you mean 'the hair whip?'"
And she said,
"You have to fully
commit to the hair whip.
All of these divas really
know how to whip their hair,
and if you don't do it correctly,
it will land in your face."
So, you know, as she says there,
you can't, you can't think side...
I don't even know if
I can do it right now.
You can't think side-to-side, okay JB?
- You gotta swing up.
- You gotta think, fall, fall.
- Oh my God. See? See?
- I was like, I don't
know if it's gonna work.
- You are so natural at it though.
(laughter)
- That was good. You nailed it.
(laughter and clapping)
- Your hair is just blowing.
- We'll put the hair in later.
Put the hair in later.
- Yeah, extensions. CGI.
(laughter)
- Oh my God, that was incredible.
- Full disclosure, I was very very nervous
and very intimidated about the singing.
And now I just like play,
you know how you have your,
whatever your Rocky song is?
And I was like,
"What doesn't kill you makes you stronger."
"What doesn't kill you-"
- Oh my God.
- And I was literally like,
I can do this. I have three days.
But if I just sing from the heart.
And I'm like,
what are you guys thinking voice wise?
You know, like Kelly Clarkson.
I'm like, whoa.
You're thinking like, the
best singer of our generation.
Not gonna happen in three days.
But I'm gonna do my best-
- Oh my God, you were so great.
It was so great.
- Yeah, so you were my muse
and I just wanted you to know that.
- You are very kind.
You're always so nice to me.